marseille et puis en premier lieu les
différents événements qui ont marqué la
journée internationale des femmes
manifestation en début de soirée à paris
organisée par la coordination des
groupes femmes il y avait près d'un
millier de personnes réclamant des
droits nouveaux la liberté de
l'avortement et la solidarité avec les
femmes polonaises dominer les slogans et
puis sur une banderole les élections
passent nos exigences reste le
gouvernement avec la présence de pierre
mauroy et celle de madame yvette roudy
en profité pour dresser le bilan de son
action au cours de l'inauguration d'une
exposition consacrée à la résistante
danielle casanova morte en déportation
pour réduire les inégalités entre les
hommes et les femmes monsieur moreau a
insité sur la formation professionnelle
les femmes sont plus durement touchées
que les hommes par le chômage mais le
ministre des droits de la femme en amour
ou dix chiffres à l'appui à dénoncer le
sexisme de cette formation
professionnelle